je suis venue l'heure du midi près d'une
école secondaire
pas besoin d'attendre très longtemps
pour apercevoir des jeunes vapoteurs
attaque au mans parce que je suis à la
cigarette puis j'aimais pas le goût de
l'assiette pis si ce paquet pour changer
le goût et l'odeur mêlant de champagne à
17 ans il va pas depuis deux ans il fait
partie d'une tendance lourde observée
partout au canada
les statistiques officielles qu'on a un
date de 2017 qui ont dans le contexte
canadien on était déjà dans une hausse
par rapport à 2014 2015
on parle d'une hausse qui est
équivalente à 60 5% au niveau 2 du
secondaire 4 et 5
après plusieurs sorties de directions
d'école et d'enseignants santé canada
reconnaît le problème et a donc lancé
une série de consultations
parmi les mesures envisagées pour
restreindre le vapo tâche chez les
jeunes la restriction de la vente en
ligne
la limitation de concentration de la
nicotine mais surtout l'interdiction de
produits aromatisés
si les saveurs alléchantes sont en
grande partie responsables de l'attrait
des jeunes pour ces produits confirme
une étude américaine déposée lors de ces
consultations fédéral on avait vu le
fléau des petits cigarillos aromatisés
on se retrouve avec cette même
problématique le haut niveau des prix
des produits de potages même de gros
joueurs de l'industrie du tabac comme on
mène benson and hedges d'une filiale du
groupe philip morris international se
dit en faveur d'un meilleur encadrement
tout en mettant en garde contre les
extrêmes qui pourrait aliéner les
adultes qui tentent d'arrêter de fumer
avec le vha potage mobile caloporteur
pour la coalition québécoise pour le
contrôle du tabac il y a urgence d'agir
si les élus du fédéral qui ont causé le
problème avec une législation qui était
inappropriée qui était inédit inadéquate
avant de quitter pour l'heure la relâche
estivale puis les élections et doivent
corriger la législation santé canada dit
n'avoir aucun échéancier pour présenter
les recommandations retenues
certains groupes de santé crainte donc
que rien ne soit fait avant la prochaine
rentrée scolaire
cet automne et c'est jacques andré
charbonneau radio canada montréal